hi everyone it's jerry i have another
cool chess puzzle to share with you
number 21 now in this playlist
i recall first being introduced to this
one about seven years ago
and it made a lasting impression on me
that's for sure
i think regardless of your skill level
you can enjoy this one
it's from 1912 composed by w.e rudolph
it's white to move
feel free as usual to pause the video
and see if you can find the best
continuation
okay now for the solution
bishop to a4
black has two options
best is to take the bishop
if he goes to c4 white will win
in the following way
with the bishop check
c4
the bishop returning to a4 and now black
must lose both rooks and soon
will be losing the game
therefore
king takes bishop is necessary
and now as i said earlier
this one made a lasting impression on me
well here's why this following sequence
b3 check
king b5 only move c4 check king c6 the
only move d5 check
king d7 the only move
e6 check
and after king takes bishop
f5
what do we have here i'm not sure what
we call this maybe some type of ultimate
pawn chain it's completely locked
black even though
he has two rooks and a bishop simply
cannot enter
the white position
this is a dead draw
unless you're playing by some checkers
rule where if you can take you must take
it's just not the case here
if the rook ever goes in the line of
fire
you just don't take it the files don't
open up the diagonals don't open up
and as mentioned a dead
draw
a very cool one in my opinion
feel free to share what you think of
this one in the comments section below
hope you're having a great day and i'll
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care bye
you